theta is messy it's often unbalanced
mislabeled and sprinkled with wacky
values to throw off your analysis
machine learning train the first step to
getting your dataset cleaned up is
understanding where it needs cleaning
today I've gotten just the tool for the
job understanding your data is the first
step to getting your data set cleaned up
for machine learning but this can be
tricky to do especially in any sort of
generalizable manner an open source
project from Google research called
facets can help us visualize our data
and slice it in all sorts of manners
which can help us begin to see how our
data set is laid out by allowing us to
find where our data doesn't quite look
the way we're expecting facets helps
reduce mishaps down the road let's see
what fastest looks like the team has a
demo page on the web so you can try out
facets from chrome without installing
anything
moreover facets visualizations use
polymer web components backed by
typescript code so you can easily embed
this in web pages and into Jupiter
notebooks there are two parts to facets
facets overview and facets deep dive
let's take a look at each one now in
more detail facets overview gives well
an overview of your data set in previous
videos we saw how tools like pandas can
help us get a sense of how our data set
is distributed we can get a slightly
upgraded view of this type of
information using the facets overview
tool facets overview splits the columns
of our data into rows of salient
information showing stuff such as
percentage missing min and Max values as
well as stats like mean median and
standard deviation it also has a column
that shows the percentage of values that
are zeroes which totally helps with
catching cases or most of your values
are zeroes you can also see these
distributions on your test data set as
well as your training set for each
feature this way you can double check
that the test set has a similar
distribution to the training dataset
yes indeed technically this is best
practice to do at least this level of
analysis on your own anyway but I have
definitely forgotten to check all of
these aspects of every column of my data
this tool will help ensure that you
don't miss this crucial step and it
highlights some abnormalities now let's
take a look at facets deep dive this is
where things get really interesting it
allows you to have even more clarity
into your data set and zoom all the way
in to see an individual piece of data
you can facet the data by row and column
across any of the features of your data
set this will look familiar to views
when you're shopping online for say
shoes and filter by different categories
such as size brand and color let's take
a look at a concrete example of deep
dive in action the interface is divided
up into four main sections the main area
in the center is a zoomable display of
your data on the left hand panel is
where you can change the arrangement of
your data with various dropdowns
to control things like faceting
positioning and color directly below
that is a legend for the center display
and on the far right is a detailed view
of a specific row of data you can click
on any thought of data in the center
visualization to see a detailed readout
of that particular data point now let's
see how this all comes together to do
this we'll use the census data set a
classic data set extracted from the 1994
US census by Barry Becker its target is
to predict whether a house calls annual
income is above or below $50,000 based
on various census statistics we'll first
split the data by age range and color
the data points based on the target
value here blue means less than 50k and
red means greater than 50k now we can
look at the breakdown by age of another
feature of the data say do different
number of hours per week yield different
results across age ranges let's find out
by faceting
columns by hours per week we can see
that there is a larger chunk of the age
17 to 26 population working 15 to 29
hours per week which may just be the
result of kids doing summer jobs let's
say and we can also see the trend of
fewer and fewer people working 29 to 43
hours per week as they get older
while the 43 to 57 hour segment stays
relatively constant in the middle years
of the chart but this still doesn't
quite show us what we are looking for so
let's try changing the positioning of
the plot and getting a more detailed
look well switch the positioning to
scatter and only facet by age I'm also
going to select hours per week as our
vertical sort order to make it easy to
see the working hours across different
age groups now we can see that indeed
the hours per week rise in the middle of
the chart and lower on either side you
should continue exploring this data and
see what transferring relationships you
can fund for instance you might facet by
country of origin which would show that
the data is heavily skewed and this
might tell you that you need to collect
more data points to have a more balanced
data set if this was interesting you're
probably wondering how to get your data
set loaded into facets well here you
have two options you can either use the
web interface and just upload the data
directly and play with it in the browser
or you can install the library as a
jupiter notebook and extension using the
instructions on the project's github
page which i'll link below facets is a
useful tool for peering into your data
and seeing the relationships between
different features as well as ensuring
that there aren't missing or unexpected
values in your data set thanks for
watching this episode of cloud AI
adventures be sure to subscribe to the
channel to catch future episodes right
when they come out now go out there and
facet your data and see how you can
improve your machine learning